and you're getting people in the  buildings clorox the sponsor associated  here with the warriors that's why chase  center is so amazing you see it on the  back of the  chairs for the players but you know  great job of the west oakland middle  school and clorox and the warriors being  in the community and juan is gone  anderson that's one thing about him he's  generous with his time as are a lot of  these warriors  they're really  making sure that they give back  there's a tremor in the force because  steph curry just missed a free throw  it's always shocking and his steph is  thinking i'm the greatest free throw  shooter of all time it shouldn't happen  to me what's wrong with this rim someone  check this  [Music]  [Applause]  drops in the second  pretty entertaining second quarter